coming to you in five four three two
welcome everybody to the hot takes
central where we're serving up hot
relevant takes like a recycled slice of
chucky cheese pizza with me today is the
beautiful and courageous courageous ela
klein round of applause how are you
today you learn that I'm not tired yes
today we had to step it up we had to do
it earlier because three o'clock let's
be honest folks it's the worst time to
do a podcast all I want to do a three
o'clock is lay down and die like
literally I'm that energy list but as
you could tell right now it is uh as we
are recording this 10:50 a.m. we
wouldn't live a little bit early and I
am like a rocket ship I've got energy
coming out all of my orifices now let me
ask you this since I'm buzzing you uh
fresh do ever do ever put down your
pants to fart so the fart doesn't go
through your underwear your pants no you
don't do that you're talking about your
fart like it's liquid or something no
but sometimes it's so dank like in a bad
way like I mean dank in the classical
sense like they say it's like Oh muy
snow Dungeness okay sometimes my farts
are so nasty I take down my pants and I
fart outside because also well that's
for your benefit because you complain
that they're so bad you actually get
angry at me like oh I like I have
control over how big I was okay so I go
to the bathroom the part but I don't
want to crop dust so I put my pants down
I let the gas go untethered by as long
as you do it in the bathroom but I would
yeah
and so I don't want to bring the scent
back with me cuz you're it was so toxic
though that no matter where you did it
it still came back we get it a little
vegan farts that I'm talking to ya the
vegan farts were so brutal every
a problem like yeah it was it was
damaging our relationship Eva actually I
would wake up in the middle of the night
from the stink mm-hmm
/ fart it's kind of satisfying though to
have so now only farts no it's kind of
it feels like an achievement like no but
I think Eva started thinking and meat
into my food but at first the farts were
so foreign to me they I didn't even
enjoy the smell of it like at first I
was like dude that's someone else's
farts and I can't enjoy it and not only
that at some point it's smelled like and
yeah I thought you said but it's not
like a sulfur mine in like Indonesia
where people like that yeah oh no it was
horrible like actually the worst smell
it literally smelled like you know when
you're a kid and you would buy stink
bombs yeah it smelled like a stink bomb
when you smell stink bomb you're like oh
that's it smells awful but that's way
worse than any fart I've ever not like
once a day or twice it's like every five
minutes
yeah exactly LA City had the valve open
except they were quiet and deadly yes I
gotta tell you though the smell grew on
me no because in a in a sense the
stinkier you're far the more the more
lonely you're gonna be no no their
people know what I'm talking don't act
like you don't know what I'm talking
about when you know I disagree with this
homeless thing stop you're being
ridiculous when you lay down your own
nasty fart and we'll move off this topic
soon enough no God I do it man
I'm buzzing here thank you to Robin Hood
hymns and mint noble with whom I without
their help I wouldn't be eating my super
healthy vegan toxic diet
no thank you imma save them toys because
Robin Hood hems and mint mobile
thank you as I was saying but I gotta
tell people that my mom was here for two
weeks she came to visit so I told my mom
it makes like the best food on the
planet so I told it and you gotta eat
her food while she's here but you only
get that once a year yeah and I don't
feel like weird about it so each and
broke the vegan diet mm-hmm which was
approved by everyone yeah but the farts
are left they're gone the other gone
there's no farts yeah I was I honestly
was so fascinated by you would think
that when you stop consuming dairy and
meat that like everything would clean up
yeah but for me I had the opposite
effect like my body went into turmoil I
mean my poops were like they were like
diarrhea that was blended up with
explosive like diarrhea wasn't enough it
was like it was like nint fruit and Jed
what do you call those blenders oh yeah
the ninja bullet yeah it's like pooping
a bullet so gnarly is it gnarliest I
mean guys I hate to talk about this
button it's my show okay I told you I
had hot ticks used to know where they
were this hot ever pull your pants down
to fart Dan or Zach I mean not on the
regular but yeah not on the red yeah
maybe after like a long weekend of
drinking or something all right you got
to take extra precaution now was that
because to avoid the smell of because
you're afraid you're gonna [ __ ] your
pants
okay now Dan I have to contest that
because I would feel that pulling down
your pants to avoid [ __ ] your pants
migi with [ __ ] on the floor or whatever
well I I go into a safe zone okay so
basically that sounds like you're
sharding sounds like you're just blowing
explosive diarrhea sighs I said it was
just a precaution
yeah then it didn't actually happen but
you know to do it at risk
has it ever have you ever pulled down
your pants to sort out a little poop no
not that I can recall
but I suppose it may have happened it
may have happened the drunker you are
the more likely it is to happen but the
less likely you are to remember
so okay it's very diplomatic answer yeah
so guys happy Valentine's Day speaking
of diarrhoea Valentine's Days was
yesterday and poor Kenny G you guys
probably saw this was in the news Kenny
G is rumored to still be in Kanye's
living room today he was hired by Kim
Kardashian are now had that back on yet
Kanye hired Kenny G to perform for Kim
Kardashian and here we have the video
this was huge news huge uses and I don't
know what worked last time
yeah it's so strange oh it's make me are
you gotta bog in the watch videos I bet
you suck my mother up in a little packet
what do I do about this maybe I'll try
it going incognito like I'm kind of
already incognito this is this is a
puzzler yeah let's see if this works
that we works you know people such a
hacker yeah if you need any IP ho call
your boy guys here's I to tips from
ether incognito or restart this is 99%
of all problems
[Music]
YouTube's gonna be like oh sorry did I
hear it yeah did I hear an echo a jazz
song mm-hmm Sony Music's like excuse me
echo II jazz anything did I hear no did
I hear one music note and then
Paramount's like excuse me Sony did I
hear a music note I went to fighting
over it like [ __ ] by the way I listen
to radio they play songs all the time
and if you play one little they play
songs that doesn't mean that you get to
own their whole show no it's insane
Sony's be like uh sharp yeah I own that
now yet Kenny G had a E sharp in his
1930 new track sharp yeah that's mine oh
that's my property now thank you
talk to my lawyers I'm Sony eat my
unwashed [ __ ] sincerely so many
lawyers
anyway Kenny G is playing music you know
this copyright nonsense is making this
everything so much more young on YouTube
and every time we finish the episode we
go back and then we're like oh we got
claimed by oh yeah our last step got
claimed what was it far a movie trailer
oh yeah movie trailer from tip toes from
[ __ ] like mm Sony's like we gotta
collect every dollar that we can off of
this movie
Sony's like do I smell a trailer from
2003 we own you
do I smell Kenny G did Kenny do you just
pull down his pants and rip of fat one
eye we owned that sound it's getting so
ridiculous and I'll tell you what what's
happening it's not necessarily YouTube's
fault there's all these predatory people
who have built their own algorithms to
detect music like a whole business so
they here's what happens you have one
mother-loving piece of ass boob who he
goes he makes an algorithm
to text music okay independent of
YouTube's and then he'll approach all
these huge companies and say hey listen
I'm gonna Rev share with you 50% all you
have to do is give me permission to
claim your [ __ ] and they're like that
sounds great that's a win-win
proposition we're already not claiming
it and he says he's gonna pay us like a
million dollars a year that's awesome
but so they have no oversight and nor do
they care because the the motivation
behind this this company that's claiming
all this [ __ ] is just to eat up as much
revenue as possible you know what I mean
so there's no well I guess the problem
on YouTube side is that there's no
motivation there's no incentive they
don't get punished for wrongly claiming
something so apparently according to the
people I've spoke to that's not true
they do get punished
apparently they say that but what's at
rampant right now is he was giving me a
really sly smirk I don't buy it I don't
know if you saw that but she's like but
well be that as it may whether they are
punishing or not
what's so rampant is this the nuance the
gray space of being like oh that was one
second of Kenny cheese so now we own
your to our plans
that is crazy it's the nuance it's the
the problem is that I think the law has
such a wide gap that it allows that and
the technology is caught up there's no
motivation it's just it's gotten it's so
out of control there's there's no
incentive for these companies not to do
it there's no rules to enforce the
opposite the law is fuzzy it's just a
feeding ground there's probably so many
videos will get claimed and the creators
don't even know it is because it's just
like you don't really get like a big
notification about it so they probably
make so much money off of the ones that
go unnoticed to that's what I get a lot
but I think the biggest issue that I've
run into talking to other creators is
people who don't understand
and are afraid to dispute it because I'm
so scared it sounds scary like yeah
you're gonna get sued if you dispute or
striked or your video gonna be erased so
you know it's it's bad it's so bad you
know
but I again is you've got to acknowledge
the opposite that on Instagram and
Facebook there is no oversight yeah
people just it's waste so far the other
side then you end up with so flow yeah
exactly so blowing suck Jerry and fat
Jew by the way fat you there's a guy
named fat Jew that does like [ __ ] Jerry
can you all get like real names I have a
conspiracy theory that these idiots fat
Jew and [ __ ] Jerry there I can't even
mention them without my video being
removed yeah like oh anti-semitic fat
Jew Jerry try to talk to making video
about [ __ ] Jerry putting them in the
title can't do it if I make a new
channel I'll call it I'll call it Hitler
I don't know I'll call it not see the
big Jewish big fat jewy [ __ ] did you yes
you're a big bad we can't did you could
learn what no we did it and nobody will
fat Jew it's like sorry you don't get to
call yourself that I don't care if you
are fat and Jewish fat Jew sorry oh I'm
so I'm so veiny I'm so I'm so awful walk
Jerry he just steals [ __ ] his Instagram
really yeah Instagram is turned into the
new Facebook where it's just like that's
mine now and I'm gonna monetize it
[ __ ] Jerry I've been doing a lot of
research on these guys man these guys
are cold-blooded so these guys are so
flow with suits your I'm saying
well they're like sofala but smarter
somehow they like walk around like
entrepreneurs they're smart they're so
flow there's they have no moral compass
and they saw a weak spot but they're
smarter not much I mean he's not that
smart but he's smarter like so blue he
would not beat this guy in chess most
likely Wow
so flu doesn't think so yeah he's been
playing checkers somebody's playing
checkers
I think sofa was playing checkers in
this case be that as it may they always
I've just read this article they own
[ __ ] Jerry owns this tequila company
yeah yeah really
which means ha ha in Spanish and none of
these guys are Hispanic none of them are
have anything to do with alcohol or
distillery or anything everything to do
is so trashy tasteless an annoying and
you'll notice when you go to [ __ ] Jerry
they're always tagging yeah yeah uh-huh
he's always wearing hats I thought it
was a sponsor and [ __ ] no he owns this
company didn't so Flo do something just
like that - he was like drop shipping
bras yeah he mentioned I don't know dude
so Flo so deep into scams I can't even
follow Zeki I bring in bras from China
and sell him on Facebook ads I make a
million dollars a second I was like what
bro I don't know he's driving around
with helicopters with ugly girls you
know that guy's on another plan he was
doing that as a kindness right yeah yeah
nicest thing he's ever done yeah I was
like so Flo what's the nicest thing
you've ever done
well I flew around on ugly girl on a
helicopter once was like bro why are you
even looking at that girl
well yeah everyone's like why you
spending time with the ugly group rogue
he's like it's like Make A Wish make a
wish came true
anyway we're talking about Kenny G but I
just got fired up so I can't help when I
see this scene with Kenny G mm-hmm I
just think of Curb when um Larry got
this for Cheryl mm-hmm you think he
nicked his idea no but it's just so
funny I feel like okay I have a lot of
thoughts about this so first of all
Kenny G's do people listen to Kenny G
he's like the weirdest corniest music
I've ever heard in my life
I love Kenny G do you you would you're
like a music connoisseur but he's just I
mean he's a dude with a flute mm-hmm not
a flute but I'm not what does he play
what is that instrument tech it's like a
it's a saxophone
it's a saxophone it's a soprano sax huh
[ __ ] do you guys know what do you guys
become scholars he kind of looks like
Howard Stern yeah the darkness but I I
imagine he was lowered into that room on
like wires like Mission Impossible and
he's still standing there to this day
they're like okay you stand here and now
we're gonna build all these flowers
around if I can now where you can't move
do you think they did that or do you
think he tiptoed I don't think he could
tiptoe without knocking that [ __ ] over
so they must have built it around him to
tell you the truth what I really think
yeah probably not that funny I think
they just left the trail and once you
walked in they closed it you know for
the video that's brilliant that's really
smart that's probably what they did do
and you can see there's not that much
space between him and the back door he's
much further away from the camera than
he is the back door so but be that as it
may I likely think he was suspended by
cable and lowered yeah I choose to
believe that it's bar funnier he's wild
playing the saxophone yeah he's like a
little flower himself isn't he like to
dip him into a vase you know what I'm
saying he's like a human q-tip he's got
a big-ass [ __ ] mop like the cleaner
and I'm saying like blue zocalo flirting
himself you know I'm saying damn I don't
know why people like Kenny G right
people want to [ __ ] Kenny G is that a
thing I'm not familiar but it sounds
like he's do you want a musical agent
he's somewhat of a mute oh he's a sex
icon Kenny G in fact I'm surprised you
brought him over because if I was Kim
Kardashian I would be alike
let's just put you in a vase and see
Kanye later yeah that's the sex icon
love that hair yeah that hair I could
get lost in that I got to find young
Kenny G because that's when he was bald
and beautiful
well he's still bald and beautiful look
at this [ __ ] not change his
hair in decades I mean god bless the man
dude look how hot he is and look at that
G to that Jesus spoke tastefully done
you know why they call him Kenny G
because he's killed five people on the
streets where he's from Compton he's in
a rich kenny OG they call him on the
streets you know they call him Kenny G
cuz he's got five different families by
five different baby mamas cuz he's a
gangster so damn he looks so much better
with his like a stylist hmm you know I'm
saying like just a dude sex God right
like there's a stylist you know what
I've been thinking about lately if all
you guys at home who are like I [ __ ]
am ugly and nobody wants to touch my
dick nobody wants to have anything to do
with me being attractive is so much just
about putting in the effort mm-hmm
I feel like almost most people if they
dress well and take care of their looks
and exercise could be extremely [ __ ]
that's true you know
and there's a luckless class up here
there's a lucky few who are just like
ridiculously naturally beautiful yeah
but those are almost like like you know
yeah but I was gonna say it doesn't
always add to the interest factor in
them like what you're describing is very
true like you could take a very normal
looking dude but if you put in the
effort look at Kenny G look at this
[ __ ] nerd I like to break his glasses
this guy I'll [ __ ] it to y'all [ __ ]
I'll go gay for a night Kenny oh gee
easily but also that's not to say that
people who aren't naturally beautiful
aren't elevated but it's not even and
for you guys are all saying oh that's
not fair I'm a lazy I'm lazy the beauty
aspect it's it's it shows that you work
that you care you know that you're
focused and dedicated it doesn't mean
that you're super it doesn't it can mean
if you take it too far
mm-hmm but there's a certain there's a
healthy medium there's a healthy point
where you take care of yourself you look
good you floss you go to clip comm /a
something else this upset but I'm saying
you take care of yourself and it says
more about you as a person and then
therefore people want to fist your
[ __ ] more than they would interesting
right somehow I defied all those advice
I just gave you because I was a mess
when I met you you you were a mess but
you actually had some style you weren't
like cool sweaters when no one else was
that's what you says got her sweater
that's what it was cool and wise I will
own that sweater I bought it from the
gap what was the sweater it was a gap
sweater but it was ice water you can add
a bunch of sweaters actually
right I have to tell I was he almost was
like dressing like a hipster but not
knowingly it wasn't like an annoying
hipster say it say what it was it was
before the hipsters that's true though
has my fashion sense I guess I don't
know because once I you know I don't
what do you think about how I dressed
these days you're my stylist dealer no
you're just fine it's I think what
happened
so you gained weight that's so true
are there to address my mood it's so
hard to dress nice with you yeah or even
chubby it's so hard to dress nice when
you're chubby
it's just try to put on a cute sweater
when you're fat it just doesn't work you
look like a marshmallow you look like a
damn fruit roll-up good thanks no I'm
not saying that what the hell we doing
here where we talking about Dan how long
has it been - when you take a look at kg
I mean - case in point from this is just
telling you so I'm just go back to that
kid picture I got to see that again
the juice did you think that anyone who
knew this kid at this time thought that
this guy would be superstar huh yeah I'm
telling you man there's hope for anyone
the most [ __ ] up broke looking ass out
there I'm not asked I mean but like
you're just broke your it [ __ ] born
with the you did your DNA got [ __ ] up
when you came out your parents [ __ ]
God was like this [ __ ] gonna be
ugly
even you do it if you put in an app
telling you if you put in the effort you
wash your [ __ ] face cut your hair put
on a cute sweater yo you're gonna be
fine mm-hmm real just a little
motivation here for you guys on Friday
afternoon now if it's so sick oh yeah my
mom arrived sick and the whole first
five days over visit here she was just
laying on our couch which really sucks
but then she got better but then Ethan
got sick was like the worst illness I've
had in so long I just lost a week of my
life basically hmm I had it like a
hundred and three point three fever you
know I was like oh my god this is
getting kind of bad it's the kind of
sick where you cannot even enjoy that
you're sick
cuz most of the time when you get sick
you're like this is nice taking it easy
watching television and not a care in
the world you're so uncomfortable
you're so much you know discomfort that
you can't even enjoy the fact that you
have nothing to do yeah so I had like
103 plus fever so I went took a cold
shower cuz you're you're I think I I
don't know if this is like the ultimate
tip that people don't know or if I just
learned it late but when when you have a
fever
you're intuitionists they bundle under
the blankets because your body heat is
so high that you feel cold by comparison
to the air temperature and so that's why
when you like get under the blankets and
you're under like ten blankets and
you've got like heaters on and you're
still cold under there is because your
body temperature is so hot that your own
body heat can't warm you to a
comfortable level so what you're doing
is just raising your temp body
temperature more and more and more
mm-hmm and that's when you can get
dangerously feverish so the best thing
you can do what I learned when I was in
Israel the last time I had a fever and
got really scared because you want to be
like I'm freezing I want to go take a
hot shower more than anything but that's
the opposite that'll make you [ __ ]
sick so you go take a cold shower and
you lay out under your
beds with no blanket or a thin sheet in
your underwear and then your body
temperature is able to lower so I did
that and I went from like 103 plus down
to like 102 which was a huge difference
because it kept going up and yeah but I
was getting scared and then from there I
just started feeling better but it took
a while money on tab biotics now give me
10 for 10 days I'm like socks 10 days
mm-hmm forget why I'm taking this in the
first believe a day 10 the walls gonna
be built by day 10 I don't think we need
antibiotics anymore is that what the
wall does and does everything it does
everything everything you ever wanted
Oh logic uh the hip-hop superstar logic
Bobby Tarantino is coming next week dan
is that at the regular timers on
Thursday it's on Thursday Thursday could
you mind Dan throwing up a questions
thread when we're finished here or
whatever of course dude do you know what
time in the day though we're not yet I
guess I don't know yet I think it's at
3:00 okay it's at our old normal time
okay I'll check with him and see maybe
we can finagle it because I really do
prefer this time but yeah Bobby is a
great guy such a sweetheart I'm very
excited to have him he's interesting
dude yeah his hands are gonna be excited
too they've been asking for it for like
a year really well we were gonna have
him on today but actually he got an
invite from Eminem I'm open for him for
like 30,000 people in Hawaii he's like
yo sorry I got to do this I was like bro
you [ __ ] me big to Oz believe how good
you know that's amazing that's really
exciting so well I plan to talk about
when we have him here yeah yeah week we
have covered literally nothing of what I
planned but isn't that the point I'm not
sticking to the script anymore this is
Danny I'm good to talk about how
I gained like 20 pounds already want to
talk about that - you want to talk about
it but we can do it after the break okay
this is Ethan Unchained as what I was
gonna say okay I am NOT sticking to the
script anymore this is who I am this is
who I want to be I'm here I'm there I'm
everywhere okay and if you don't like it
then you can file an official complaint
at podcast at issue of your productions
calm you can be back is always welcome
with that being said let's throw to a
quick commercial break we've got
everything to talk about we have not
covered nearly we have not talked
cleared anything clearly
everything's left to talk about don't go
away Robin Hood is an investing app that
lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options Kryptos all commission free
while other brokerages charge up to $10
for every trade Robin Hood doesn't
charge any Commission free so you could
trade stocks and keep all the profits
plus there's no account minimum deposit
needed to get started so you can start
investing at any level the simple
intuitive design of Robin Hood makes
investing easy for newcomers and experts
alike view easy understand charts and
market data and place a trade in just
four taps of your smartphone you can
also view stock collections such as 100
most popular with Robin Hood you can
learn how to invest in the market as you
build your portfolio discover new stocks
track your favorite companies and get
custom notifications for price movements
so you never miss the right moment to
invest Robin Hood is giving listeners of
the h3 podcast a free stock like Apple
Ford or sprint to help you build your
portfolio a free stock folks what do you
got to do go sign up at h3 podcast Robin
Hood gum for a free stock to build your
empire and your legacy that's me they
didn't write that in the copy that was
mine words
tik-tok mother effers does balding run
in your family well I got bad news for
you 66% of men lose their hair by the
age of 35 and the thing is when you
notice your hair is gone is little
coming out it's already too late
but here's the good news guys it's not
all dreary and rain there's sunshine
over there because it's easier to keep
the hair you have on your head that to
replace it once it's gone down the drain
am i right
I don't know anything about hair loss
unfortunately for myself but these guys
do it for hips calm okay
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men here's the deal
you don't have to lose your hair you
don't have to be bald it's optional
because we got real doctors real medical
grade solutions to treat the hair loss
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions we'll help you
keep the dang hair on your head and out
of the drain this is not a snake oil
pill or a gas station supplement this is
prescriptions backed by science okay
these are dudes in white labs who said
hey don't keep the hair on this guy's
[ __ ] head it's in this pill I wonder
if it makes your pubes go crazy because
by the same logic if it keeps the hair
in here it's gotta make your pubes go
crazy too I don't know I don't take this
I have hair unlike you I'm like
consolidating that well you can want
this no waiting room no awkward person
doctors that save hours like going to
four hems calm it's so freakin easy all
you do is answer a few quick questions
the doctors will review and prescribe
you the products are shipped directly to
your door you are gonna end guys we've
got a great offer my listeners get a
trial month of hymns for just five
dollars today right now while supplies
last see you the website for full
details this will cost you hundreds of
dollars if you went to the doctor or
pharmacy like a SAP but you're not a SAP
that's why you're gonna go to forums
comm /h 3 fo r hims comm /h 3 for hims
com /h 3 for 5 bucks we're gonna keep
that beautiful head of hair yours on
your head where it belongs it out of the
drain
there's a lot of things in life that are
right carpeting showers eating tip with
your fingers chunky styled milk and
paying too much for your dang phone bill
that ain't right
but thanks to Mint mobile you don't have
to overpay for Wireless anymore and let
me just say hallelujah okay
they've reimagined the wireless shopping
experience it made it easy and online
only which means that they could pass
significant savings directly on to you
and for a limited time they are offering
two months free when you buy your first
about that's 20 bucks total for three
months of wireless not only is this
amazing deal here for a limited time for
20 bucks you get three months of
wireless service with eight gigabytes of
4gl to you
data each month plus unlimited
nationwide talk and text that's right
you know I didn't stutter that's too
0:20 use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan you could keep it old phone
number along with all of your existing
contacts they just send you this
beautiful little card in the mail that's
the SIM card all sizes appropriate pop
it in there and Bob is in fact your
uncle at the DNA results are in Bob is
your uncle
mint mobile runs on the nation's fastest
most advanced LTE networks and if you're
not 100 satisfied mint Mobile's got you
covered with their seven day money-back
guarantee Wow
what do you got to lose except a bunch
of money that you're wasted on these
other clouds take advantage of mint
Mobile's amazing deal before it's gone
pay just 20 bucks for your first month
of wireless and get another two months
for re by going to mint mobile.com slash
h3 that's mint mobile.com slash issue to
get three months of premium wireless
service for just $20 mint mobile.com
slash you guess it h3
one have you heard this 21 savage song
uh a lot to find that 21 savage saw a
story he got arrested by ice but I
really like that song dude I mean it
didn't you got a lot it's like this
equal to e for D fo d yup nope starving
nope dinner
yup that's gangster that's more even
that's more G than Kenny G afraid of the
dark games oh yeah yes goes a good
friend of the dark nope like that's
gangster and then he goes Yoda yeah so
so 21 savage came out with the sequel -
yup nope called a lot a lot where he
poses questions to himself and the
answer is always how many money how much
money you got a lot yeah exactly call
and response just like the folk classics
how many lawyers you got a lot so I was
trying to think like what would my
version that song be you know how many
how much money you got some how many
[ __ ] you got one sorry [ __ ] I just
it's the vernacular how many pockets you
got one how many channels you got three
I don't stick to the format
yeah I like to mix it up how many
consoles you play three let me with that
vibe very realistic
yeah very realistic eight eight eight
how many showed you God one how many
[ __ ] you got one zero
how BIG's your dick little eight how
many dogs you got none friends I mean
friends yes
how much how BIG's your bank account
it's pretty good yeah how many how many
viewers you got how many mill happy late
in a day - how many pounds you lost for
how much you weighed 210
that's pretty fat are you obese yup do
you watch movies not that much
do you like Netflix it's okay do you
watch Hulu it's okay do you want cable
nope
do you like dish nope do you like
commercials nope do you like paying $100
for commercials no just yeah yeah do you
love your wife yup is she gonna have a
baby yes
I'm forgetting the point of the song how
many yeah how many how many babies are
you gonna have one well maybe more how
many babies are gonna have a lot how
many crews you work with Wow one
yeah where's my crap how many grams you
won not one
yeah grammy-nominated we bring you
Ethan the killer how many times you met
with Will Smith once fines yeah alright
so I keep going with this
nope I'm gonna be Will Smith oh we met
him in YouTube crater or summat oh he is
a youtuber they're sure of us a ch3 I'm
like a lecture not a lecture but I could
talk that he gave wait I have an epic
photo hopefully it's on Google so don't
the Will Smith have a lot of a YouTube
advice for you guys you know what that
was before II was a year okay here's an
epic photo of we did with him you know
what
YouTube's this [ __ ] is so stupid like
okay by the way you can tell how much I
don't want to talk other Creators you
know I feel there's enough of that going
around but let me just say this
Tyler Okies a [ __ ] and I'm gonna [ __ ]
him up I'm [ __ ] throw down a Tyler
Oakley I was gonna say is I was gonna
make an observation about how people
like tried to get in as close to well
Smith as possible let's just say the
people at the front of it they try to
get there they try they made an effort
yeah like as if Will Smith was Jesus
it's like the Last Supper but Tyler
Oakley uh Joey Graceffa bunch of other
people is weird I mean it was yeah Will
Smith Will Smith
he actually it was nice actually hearing
I'm not gonna say in
bad about him and on that note I'm super
excited for his role as genie I think
he's gonna crush it I think it's perfect
role for him I think Robin Williams is a
small easy shoes to fill
mm-hmm he's hack those shoes are so
small ish Will Smith is gonna be
spilling over the shoes - they're gonna
size up no he's cool he's tall as [ __ ]
he was like he's got like that movie
star yeah you know when you meet someone
they like he's got like a movie star
quality where you meet him and he's like
tall and like he's so put together and
you just feel like an inferior person
and listen I'm saying if you've ever met
a person like this you know what I'm
talking about don't judge me for saying
that he just is so polished okay his
life is probably a [ __ ] mess probably
hates his family okay
the dudes of Scientologists house some
more [ __ ] up can your life get but
like on the surface value he has this
polish he has a aura like a princely
aura is it known that he's a
Scientologist I think that it's I mean
there's like trying to keep it a secret
I don't what yeah I it's like highly
suspected but he's not like open about
it but I guess he's donated a bunch of
money to Sol ontology and like open
school or Scientologists but I got damn
when we make claims like this that are
not really backed up I prefer if you
could come in and say them instead of me
can we set that up in some way I'll push
the button I'd be like damn that I don't
know it's true or not
secret hot take button take Dan take can
you take the I'll take on this one but
I've met other people like that I met
people like that who work for Google and
YouTube where they're so put together
and so polished and I'm like what the
[ __ ] do you inject
like yeah baby foreskin for sure
mm-hmm penis facial anyway what the [ __ ]
are we doing here what do we need to
talk about today is this fun or a mess
hmm who cares I'm having fun but so 21
savagely you know what it's too serious
but they should not lock him up they
should not dumb like that I think what
was messed up is that day there was ice
put out a report that said that he came
when he was a like 14 or something and
that he had prior convictions that
criminal record and then I said Savage
put out a statement from his attorneys
that said he came when he was seven you
know and he has no criminal conviction
so that's a huge difference in reporting
what are you supposed to do when you're
seven like you don't even know yeah his
mom brought him over when he was seven
okay he's grew up his whole life here in
America it's all he knows he's got kids
his family's here his life is here he's
born in the UK but he's never lived
there he doesn't have a life there
I like how people like to port him yeah
like people say that about about Israel
they say send him back to Germany uh I
just imagine someone getting off about
and being like all right what now yeah
it's like did you dude he lives here
he's [ __ ] he lives here dude what is
your that's just cruel you want to send
it and also why did they need to arrest
him like it didn't just it's it's all
paperwork you can figure it out but he
doesn't need to be in like jail with
rapists and murderers right I heard they
had him on lockdown for 23 hours a day
and one hour of like free time and he
was out they didn't even issue him a
bomb so they wouldn't even allow him out
well I don't think he was in a normal
jail he was in a nice detention centers
yeah he was there with other people that
have been picked up by ice but I guess I
think what
men is that the conditions were like as
if he was some kind of violent affair
yeah yeah I mean I don't think a nice
Detention Center is a club fed uh was
there explosion outside do you hear that
ice is coming for me guys I forgot to
tell you I was born in the UK by Isis
here but so it turns out that what now
he's out on $100,000 bond because
there's jay-z hired like every lawyer in
America but I'm sorry that just seems
unnecessarily cruel let's forget about
his politics let's forget about his race
let's forget about anything you know
about him he's just a dude okay who came
here when he was seven as a kid his mom
overstayed the visa he went to public
school here he has a family he has a job
here his whole life is here he doesn't
he has no identity what UK and you're
just gonna arrest him what was his crime
exactly and ship him back dude if that
was somebody you knew if you erased
everything you knew about him and that
was just like a template person that you
knew I feel like 100 % of people would
say that's insane
but that that's just my opinion or I
mean I know that I don't see any other
way to see it I agree I feel bad for him
I saw many interview today and he was
like on Good Morning America it was the
first interview he gave he was like I
didn't even know what a visa was I was
seven yeah I had no idea how this would
impact my life I what growing up as an
adult I was a I was seven years old when
I came here mm-hmm
I'm American as far as I know this is
all I know also let's acknowledge that
he doesn't have a criminal record
apparently that's what his attorneys say
and he is a dis whatever you think about
his music or his politics a highly he
contributes a lot to society in terms of
his tax chair he's a big earner pays a
lot of taxes I'm sure you know hires a
lot of people so again I don't like it I
don't like it at all the whole thing
seemed really crazy and his lawyer
appointed out that it was interesting
that they did it like a week before the
Grammys I didn't go to the Grammys
because he was locked up mm-hmm and
right after he released a song that had
some lyrics criticizing the border
mm-hmm incidents with separating kids
from their family yeah his lawyers said
that they think it was related I don't
know I sat even having said it Savage
sitting there he's like I don't know I
don't know anything but just you don't
even need to mm-hmm you don't even need
to go that far to see how [ __ ] up it
is you don't need to make any conjecture
you don't have to make any guess work
without being said I was born and where
would I be born from Allah not from
America
Poland probably such a [ __ ] loser
sorry Polish people that's just a joke I
at first I don't know I think I am
probably a little polish why do people
make fun of the Polish what the [ __ ]
they do the pole locks
what's wrong - Polish people I have no
idea hmm I'm polish - I knew your second
class isn't so that's my hot hot take on
21 Savage now let's just get to Shane
because we're supposed to talk about
that is the [ __ ] title of this
podcast okay it's so hard the title and
thumbnail podcast you know I mean mm-hmm
what you really want to call it is here
we are talking about stuff episode but
nobody will click that right I don't
think so talking about stuff episode 104
let's try it next time No
[Music]
um chucky cheese okay so Shane did this
huge conspiracy series you guys may have
seen it now
here's my hot take we need like a hot
take sound fact here's Ethan's hot take
on Shane's conspiracy documentary way
too [ __ ] long I couldn't agree more I
cannot make it through those long videos
I heard all the hubbub about the Chucky
Cheese [ __ ] and I like so shane has this
conspiracy theory that chuck because the
slices are unsymmetrical and it looks
like the pieces have Frankenstein
together yeah that the theory is that
employees scoop up old slices and reuse
them in the back so he did this huge
investigation and she forced because his
views his videos get so many views
chucky cheese was forced to make a
statement like our pizzas made fresh and
it's delicious whatever you know
suspicious statement so I was like wow
this is pretty funny so let me check
this out and man this [ __ ] made
a two-hour video I mean there's plenty
of nice things to say about it and I
don't need to suck change dick because
everyone else is doing that
but this mother-fricker it was making
two hour long videos and 30 million
effin 30 [ __ ] million people watched
it so what the hell do I know basically
long for me I'm just being Frank I think
he like hacked into like YouTube's
algorithm because it's all about watch
time now people are hearing that out so
they're just letting their videos ride I
feel like that cut that video could be
20 30 minutes yeah but Shane's just like
let it ride boy 2 hours and YouTube's
like yup 110 minutes
nope want two hours yup how many minutes
how many minutes your video got a lot
how many recommended views a lot
so anyway but I did five lump thumb
through it and watch the Chucky Cheese
part I thought it was funny he was
entertaining it was very playful but it
would annoy me was that he does not
acknowledge the obvious thing that was
driving me nuts
mm-hmm because he's like driving home
the point dude he he did a takedown on
Chucky Cheese he like full-on Vince
McMahon Donald Trump you know that gif
takedown WWF style because he was trying
to build an atmosphere where somehow
chuck-e-cheeses corporate policy is to
instruct their low-level employees to
scoop up used pizza and reuse it no yeah
of course there isn't there's literally
zero percent chance okay so I have to
assume that him and and well I don't
know he never he never acknowledged that
it's not really true and that the
obvious answer is that they're making 20
pies at I'm back there and they just mix
and match them based on what you order
mm-hmm you have like a pepperoni you
have a cheese and you'll have a sausage
and people I want half pepperoni half
sausage
they don't bake a new a new one they say
I'm gonna take half of this pepperoni
I'm take half the sausage and they don't
fit perfectly together huh I cracked the
code
Thank You davinci code soft Shane I'd
like to be in your next conspiracy
theory I've never seen Chucky Cheese or
be into one dude I can't wait to take
our kid there so those characters oh
yeah I was like good I'm like the real
conspiracy is not the pizza the real
conspiracy theory is what the [ __ ] is
with these masks oh how is this
kid-friendly who is in these suits man
like these are the original furries
right not only so Chuckie Cheese is kind
of a strange place first of all you're
gambling there you are you're they
giving out tickets okay it's like an
arcade where you get tickets and you win
a bunch of useless crap mm-hmm
so it's kind of like fundamental
rudimentary gambling because you put in
coins and then you get tickets for like
it's a it's can't I mean you know the
elements are there games of chance okay
want some candy
skeeball is not a game of chance
that's a game for champions right there
well to be frank with you Dan that was a
game for the savage because that those
places are so undermanned
they even here's how worthless those
tickets are we would just walk straight
up the ramp and put it in the bull's eye
like we I had a friend there when I get
a birthday party we would sat there for
ten minutes just putting the ball like
we were sitting on the ramp and just
putting the ball in the bull's eye and
like it is inhuman to be that skilled
and the amount of tickets we got still
didn't get us anything valuable really
yeah like the amount of tickets you need
to win like a ps4 you would need to
spend like a hundred thousand dollars
and you want to take our kid there yeah
it says it's fun I like the atmosphere
but obviously what's going on with these
most that's a drawing but here this is
my favorite this is my favorite that's a
real photo okay like what the hell
they had these wrote animatronic robots
that would put on a show for you while
you ate your pizza oh my god and do like
songs and dances and [ __ ] they changed
the mascot this is the new one it's
better than that really the eyes are so
dead and sold us and uncanny you know
the eyes okay yeah all messed up but
like near one is like just look how he
looks at you oh my god yeah that's the
one that was there when I was a kid look
at this guy this guy's seen better days
do kids like this are there
right of it I like we loved it as kids
yeah yeah only now this girl didn't love
it I think that's a so at any rate so
Shane was building this atmosphere of
trying to be like make it believable
that they have a corporate policy of
scooping up old slices and we're using
it so he was showing like clips of like
news reports of fights breaking out and
kids crying and people recording like
the ball pit and there was like poop in
the ball pit there's a ton of
chuck-e-cheeses the fights did the dude
there's people fighting and
chuck-e-cheese I've got clip footy video
evidence from shameless using clips of
people fighting and I was oh oh my god
this is so much better than the actual
dude watch this I couldn't believe this
is like captivating unbelievable look at
this that Pizza salsa blood they're like
it's also blood on that whatever just
getting painful reserve it what's the
difference and attacked chuck-e-cheeses
employees in Miami when they fighting
owners as customers slugged it out with
each other don't women with hair as the
children run for cover
remove Lamar Wallace what could that's a
great question what could you possibly
be beefing over at Chuck E Cheese to
start pulling he ran through so
apparently at Chuck E Cheese they serve
beer to the parents yeah I was about to
say and it's like really cheap so no I
think that probably has something to do
with you more crazy it's like a $5
pitchers so oh wow yeah so beer to the
parents peas it to the kids
pooping the ball pen this place still
exists oh yeah and somehow Shane went
there with two other dudes without a kid
and spent the whole day there recording
and nobody said anything
like how have I never seen this place
dude there was one where I grew up
I [ __ ] my parents suck I used to look
at their longingly every time you'd be
like god I wish I could go to Chuck E
Cheese but I'm not even gonna bother to
ask with my parents [ __ ] suck so who
cares about Papa John's when you got
Chuckie Chuckie Cheese is like an event
it's like birthday party isn't [ __ ] it's
like all you spend the whole day there
you know hmm
it's the best fricking day ever and
that's kind of dope when the parents are
getting blackout drunk it's like the
best of both worlds if your trashy do
getting blackout drunk and throwing
fists at Chuck E Cheese so obviously you
know I learned a lot about Chuck E
Cheese I still want to go there and the
pizza looks bomb I mean I'm so I want
pizza yo this diets killing me I was
looking at Chuck E Cheese and I was like
I want I don't give a [ __ ] if they
reused that pizza or not I'll eat that
can we eat pizza day no okay
it's good thank you thank you gotta wait
until we got a kid how many pizza we got
you know how much Islands how much pizza
we got none
how much piece do we want some how much
family top is on that Pizza Three Olives
cheese pepperonis
that's three getting blackout drunk at
my chuck-e-cheese throwing bars and I'm
getting ready to brawl talk [ __ ] on my
son and get leveled son I'm on that
skee-ball hitting number one yo cuz son
sit on that ramp put the ball in that
mouse's mouth I've got a hundred points
every time with the ball maybe when
you're done you can afford a sour head a
head to Chuck E Cheese get flung out
drunk yeah get that pizza get that pizza
all right kill it we have fun here no
places like this in Israel that is so
American dude I know I know
I didn't as a personal bit but I mean I
mean like glorify America that it's like
so find it laughter I need your kids
pizza dave and buster's is kind of a
classy version of chucky cheese isn't it
who is that yeah exactly see you're out
of the loop baby we're gonna have a kid
you're gonna open a whole new world Dave
and Buster's is kind of like claw it's
classy Chuckie Cheese it's just like a
cool arcade game lots of games and
activities and food right am i right you
guys back yep oh really no kids odd well
I could be wrong about that I'm not a
Dave & Buster's expert I suppose it's
kind of the exact same thing because it
the appeal is that there's alcohol but
they have that at Chuck E Cheese - I
know they serve pictures at Chuck E
Cheese
oh yeah that's crazy only we get the
parents to take the [ __ ] kids you
imagine that's kind of true huh they do
real cheap too that's like so brilliant
marketing like you can come get blackout
drunk from the whole day here but the
kid is the one to change wallet can you
imagine if they serve pictures out like
Disneyland they're so smart not to serve
alcohol there yeah people probably can
you sneak out go on the Disney I guess
you could if you're really dedicated
there there is a place to get drinks in
Disneyland though but it's like a secret
right club 33 it's hot apparently this
club is very top secret mm-hmm
they time all Universal they don't give
a [ __ ] they sell beer all over the place
yeah universals trash it is trash I mean
dude I'll tell you can I [ __ ] about
universal for a minute
me neither went there recently because I
felt like doing a theme park and we
bought the VIP bracelet to skip at the
head of the line there's more [ __ ]
people with the VIP bracelet than
general admission I was at times in the
VIP line and I was like is this longer
than the general admission line any
wasn't cheap like it was twice the price
how is everyone affording this [ __ ] you
smell like a thousand dollars and all
these little like broke-ass families
running around with a VIP with like five
kids all VIP how the [ __ ] do you guys
afford it go in the general admission
line you can't afford this they gotta
like triple the price so that rich
people can get a better experience
Ian just told me that Star Wars land at
Disneyland is gonna have alcohol there
they're delving in watching yeah I guess
he's watching oh he's having a top
secret procedure though I'm not allowed
to talk about him that's all I'll say
he's having a sex-change operation when
he returns he'll be Kim what's the
female version of Ian Ivanka Ivanka all
right too long boom ah em okay whatever
where were we Chuckie Cheese Universal
sucks but the Harry Potter world is
awesome nice but there's so many [ __ ]
people there everybody wants to be a
wizard
everybody wants the wand it's not
Hogwarts where there's so many [ __ ]
kids running around with wands bricks
the illusion
Hogwarts was for wizards only not that
main muggles there
and by the way again to glorify America
yeah like in Israel the the theme parks
mm-hmm are like basically non-existent
and compared to the stuff you have here
just to explain it a little bit there's
300 million people yeah and they all
like have some money yeah so those like
what what's possible in America is
almost impossible anywhere else on earth
because there's so many people and so
much money like a place like Disneyland
our universe and so much space yeah and
there's baby have it all we really have
it all this is the best place in the
world you're not I mean let's be honest
about it
sorry Poland Poland today man
you can visit yeah I know we love the
pole locks we love we love the pole lot
of it I kid the pole ox we love you
nobody does what's a pole ok so at any
rate Harry Potter world is awesome but
we were talking about Chucky Cheese
Chuckie Cheese Chuckie Cheese statement
they said a spokesman strongly refuted
Shane's claims the claims made in this
video about Chucky Cheese and our pizza
are unequivocally false the spokesman
said no conspiracy here theory here our
pizzas are made to order and we prepare
our dough fresh and restaurant which
means that they're not always perfectly
uniform in shape but always delicious
there's some deception in this statement
because clearly they're not made to
order just say just explain what I
explained that has to be the explanation
yeah you have them queued up and you
just [ __ ] them out it's fine but there's
some deception here oh you cannot sit
you're just fueling the conspiracy
because when you say we prepare our
dough fresh that's why it's not
perfectly uniform no dude
Shane literally took out here I'll show
you guys
he took he took it so far just to prove
that they're from different pizzas he
proved it in like two seconds
it's so obvious but like he in his mind
he's proving that the employee scoop it
up and reuse it but it's your percent
zero percent let's just say that let's
just say that was all Greek that
literally does not happen Shane it
cannot
that's insane can I make an offer an
open invite to Shane after you present
every conspiracy theory bring me on to
give the counter-argument from everyone
hate me such a [ __ ] joy kill
now the place they're editing hilarious
the Chrysler should be puffy well around
so he put imeem it's funny yeah
I love his reaction this is he's looking
at a pizza that's a little unsymmetrical
this is I gotta say that one was all
pepperoni dude I don't see why you would
mix and match that one because they
mixed half already Dan it's not rocket
science they had it they have got like
five pepperoni pizzas in back what's
it's likely that they these are all
leftover slices from other people
there's no way dude there's literally
it's just first of all there's help
there's unannounced health inspections
yeah second of all you would never and
it keep you would never be able to keep
low level employees you can't operate a
business you cannot bring low every low
level employee in a fraud yeah that
violates every health code okay
SEC like also making pizzas cheap why
they have no reason to do that on a
corporate level you know what I'm saying
it's not what happens they have five
pepperonis back there half of it well
this one went to the half sausage and
then someone's like well I want a [ __ ]
pepperoni and then they had two half
pepperonis left and they combined it
it's not rocket science dan
so look at this by the way three dudes
and a chuck-e-cheese without kids taking
pictures of pizza yes we all I mean I
was like yes I agree but your conclusion
is not right
so he goes on and on to prove that does
he not eat the pizza I know I don't
think they ever took bites I would eat
that [ __ ]
I would eat that [ __ ] looks Kabam you
look look at that and tell me you don't
want to eat that looks good thank you
we're getting somewhere do you want
pizza for two no okay
so do you think that's half of a
pepperoni pizza half of the cheese
[ __ ]
I think it's 100
any hearts cut into some woman talking
about sex trafficking I was like oh my
god the wall on me there right that's
what that was about sack I didn't watch
that part uh yeah it was like she's a
youtuber and it's an old friend and this
dude like they met on like tinder or
something and he later his closet her as
far as like wanting to take her and face
birth certificates and [ __ ] like that
it's pretty gnarly to mash up Chuckie
Cheese and yes trafficking quite a
transition but the first here let me
show you the first thing cuz it's funny
it's very long and cheap it just it
annoyed me that he never like just
mentioning Chuckie Cheese they like wake
up one morning thirty million views 30
million people believing that their yeah
serving years Pizza you leftover slices
they're like what did we do what do we
do except serve $5 pitchers and get
parents blackout drop so I think we all
accept the premise see he's kind of
doing what high IQ people like me would
just call a straw man argument that's
not is that right somebody don't correct
me if I'm wrong high IQ people like
myself of 200 IQ or plus will you
describe things such as straw man
fallacy where he's setting up an
argument that doesn't exist to prove a
point that's not really provable okay so
what he's done is he's just spent all
this time trying to prove that these
came from different pizzas that is not
in dispute that's obvious the point he's
trying to prove that he has no evidence
for is do employees scoop it up and
reuse it there's zero evidence for that
and the evidence is plain that at all
that it comes from different pop from
pizza pies we've got someone here in the
chats and you worked there for two years
yeah I mean
with takis they used slice he's in on it
yeah they paid not chuck-e-cheese that's
a show can you imagine like a mute
making seven dollars an hour they're
like yo we're gonna need you to stake
use pizza and also if you tell anyone
we're gonna kill your family package
you saw what chuck-e-cheese looks like
would you say no to that guy yeah egg or
tell you tell anyone about this I'm
gonna break your [ __ ] legs capisce
you know why they call me Chucky Cheese
cuz the e stands for enemy number one
which is what I'm gonna be if you snitch
on the rap
no luck you out the window I'm like
nobody snitches on the rap capisce I'm
gonna rape your mother serious I don't
get it yeah he's got a scare these [ __ ]
I will rape your mother you understand
it I will put your mother's body into a
pizza into a human-sized pizza box
capisce I'm glad that person chimed in
though obviously and also their chains
they're all owned and operated by
different owners so some of them can be
sleazier and dirtier than other ones
probably you know either what are you
typing Oh
oh that we have chat yeah you guys can
subscribe you could become a member of
the h3 podcast just like when we were on
Twitch right and you can participate in
our chat and use all of our wonderful
badges and icons and logos
honestly I we had it open to everyone
and I think anyone who read the chat
will agree that it was such ass this is
not a money thing the chat open to the
general public is such yes I need to
pull down my pants to pass it so what we
did is we and we did a Members Only chat
and it's so much better it's actually
nice to hear from them we get a
beautiful anecdote like that one there
I'm chuck-e-cheese employee so thank you
guys
here let me show you this clip so he
like he see us eyes a picture of a pizza
and so we're not arguing yeah
do you know what I'm saying like you're
miss like we accept the premise it's not
that unbelievable it's like opening a
picture of the sky and being like look
at the hue it's blue I'm ain't dropping
it look at it on the spectrum it's like
we accept the premise look at those
greasy little [ __ ] slices I feel like
when I eat a slice of pizza I
immediately gain two pounds
[Music]
was to pieces
yeah it's not that complicated I think
they're they're good fit around I would
say it's so over the top
yeah they got to give them the benefit
of doubt that it's tongue-in-cheek
well it's definitely tongue-in-cheek and
they're definitely good for a round and
laughing but I washed every sequenced
but is it clear that it's no no it's not
that's that that's what was annoying me
and by the end he starts making serious
accusations and joking about like maybe
I should consult my lawyer and I was
like wait maybe you should mm-hmm
wouldn't it be amazing if Shane got sued
by Chuckie Cheese eight nobody snitches
on the rat capiche I don't think it
could really get sued because he's not
claiming anything to be fact right there
was one scene where he made a joke about
that where he was like I think it's a
fact that is he's like oh no I mean it's
my opinion okay it's funny though I
enjoyed it and I'm available Shane if
you need the the wet towel segment
mm-hmm if you want to bring your show
down make everybody skip forward hey
don't forget to put Pete don't forget to
put a pepperoni on my grave you know
that song don't forget to put roses on
my grave yeah don't forget to put
pepperoni on my grave here lies Chuckie
Cheese passed away from heart attack
2018-2019 here's to a real one and I see
you sitting there and blacked out from a
five-dollar pitcher your kid is lost in
the ball pit he's taking a dump in the
ball pit and there's a pedophile in the
corner
eating pizza all alone and watching your
kid while you're blacked out
how's that chorus girl don't forget to
put pepperoni on my grave shut my cheese
has announced oh he was trying to push
me on chucky cheese has announced that
they will be putting a hit on Shane
Dawson super the mouse is not happy
there's a million Pizza hit yeah what's
next
I wonder if fans got nightmares of this
character time enough time he [ __ ]
should what I see you sitting there in
your pizza upholstered chair wondering
if my pepperonis were fresh eel are you
gonna eat your placenta mm-hmm I wonder
how many people know about it because
this was news to me um from someone we
work with apparently people eat their
placenta because it's supposed to be
good for you that's the [ __ ]
afterbirth that comes surging out of
your vagina after the baby a bloody
discarded organ that the baby lived in
while it develops and there's people
that eat it it sounds awful and like you
can pay someone to dry it for you and
make pills I'm a veggie bro I swear to
god they people turkey out of it
apparently some people even just take it
as it isn't crooked fava beans and
Chianti or whatever uh to answer your
question no I will not be eating my
placenta but you know who did when I was
looking it up Kim Kim Kardashian wish
she was here to answer for that
dude I'm sorry pseudoscience has gone
too [ __ ] far let's not eat our
placentas it's so funny actually just
googled
it's eat placenta just to see what comes
up and like so many articles came came
out popped up that said you should not
eat your placenta or please don't eat
your placenta like there's no scientific
reason to do it there's no evidence of a
reason that people do it I guess is
because some mammals eat their placenta
yeah and then it turns and then the
narrative turns into all every time and
then there says while other mammals do
it so it should be good for us yeah
other mammals eat their [ __ ] I've seen
her eat his [ __ ] I don't think that's a
good idea
shredder licks his dick I would if I
could but would you suck your own dick
if you could probably and all honesty at
least at least not like all the time but
on special occasions probably so I
really don't get it but what I saw him
do she she put it in a pill and it was
like black house likes man people eating
their placenta people on vac not
vaccinating their kids I mean the world
has gone [ __ ] mad here we got smart
people doing research they got lab coats
they got I mean why are we listening to
Facebook mom's here you're gonna need
this
Washington Post don't eat your placenta
fake news people just believe whatever
they want no fake news I'll eat my
placenta Kim you're amazing placenta
that looks like literal I love that she
made it into a sponsored ad - oh yeah of
course it's up on my app and also um she
sends you to whoever the company who
made it for her gotta monetize Kim
you're amazing placenta this is your
discarded organ that has [ __ ] and blood
and feces we cleaned it out and dried
and held it for you it's supposed to
help and it's nutritious um
it's nutritious that's why you should
eat your placenta like other [ __ ]
food that isn't discarded organs they
you [ __ ] out it's nutritious yeah I'll
eat a salad I mean it up my own [ __ ]
discarded organ you could eat your tumor
you could have a cancerous tumor removed
because I mean you should eat it you
could know that they say that you should
eat your discarded cancerous tumors
because it's nutritious and I saw a
animal do it once in a nature
documentary so it has to be healthy
that's like a Alex Jones like placenta
as a baby foreskin would you rather get
a baby foreskin injection or eat
placenta you have to answer I'll take
the injection mmm yeah what till maybe
I'll look better yeah at least get the
benefit of that that might actually work
I don't know am i eating placenta
guarantee doesn't logical is eating
placenta is about as logical of a
conclusion as concluding that Chuckie
Cheese employees who make $7 an hour
scooping up you slices and serving it
back like what is their vested interest
in that make seven dollars an hour it's
like why would all these people work at
Chuck E Cheese choose to participate in
a crime for a minimum pay I can see some
sleazy like owner doing that right yeah
that's like that's like that could
happen at any restaurant a flea poop
feast 420 shadow to poop feast 420 I
used to watch Starcraft when I was a wee
lad I always think about poop feast 420
because I always thought it was the
funniest name everything that was a
player he he was a guy that you saw
always submit questions to our this guy
artosis oh sure yeah who used to
announce all the games yeah and so he
used to always get in with really good
but his name is poop feast 420 I just I
thought the image of a poop feast was so
fantastic it's not throughout the years
poop feast with weed - [ __ ] going all
out
poop feast with weed what 420 he said oh
yeah cuz he's nine and he's extra hungry
yeah I could eat
extra poop tonight I was thinking of
going to this Spencer EU after this in
California I was talking to he and the
other day I was like hey Ian has this
vape he was recommending me that's like
10-part why should I not talk about oh
my god no I just looked up fun either
cooking a placenta show me pictures oh
no it's that bad disgust well it's
basically cannibalism like socially
accepted cannibalism it looks like dude
it's it's are so foul like these are the
people that drink their own urine
because they think it's healthy you
pissed it out of your [ __ ] body okay
your body is you've is saying I don't
want this this is trash yeah this is
garbage
you don't scoop that up and then put it
back in they go they go uh you know what
will cure my cancer drinking my own
urine mm-hmm all right Steve Jobs was a
victim of that he said he's like yeah
I've got cancer but you know what's
gonna cure it instead of conventional
medicine you know what I wrote you know
what I used to think it was stupid for
that but after seeing my dad's
experience with the options they give
you it's it's it's just like you there's
just no winning when you got cancer like
what what are the options they give you
chemo and then you know well if you're
most likely gonna get off worse after
chemo it's like such a barbaric the
thing is written is he caught he had a
very curable as I
understand it I don't know you have it
they always give you all this
you have 70% chance of recovery whatever
it doesn't mean anything I just I after
seeing what my dad had to go through
with chemo he suffered so much and then
it was for nothing
mm-hmm so maybe you should just enjoy
your last year instead of suffering I
don't know yeah take the fruit option
maybe if you get some bomb smoothies out
of it I just rack in like 10 years or
something no one will do chemo I hope
not
that [ __ ] is horrible but right now
there are no other options really I
think that in your dad's case it was
very tragic because they I think the doc
they have this weird thing these doctors
they can't be real with you no they
can't they have to buy some policy
because if they fail you if they say
anything to concrete you could other
words like yeah hold them accountable to
that one statement so there won't say
anything so they're always gonna be
saying get treated didn't read it it's
curable I guess probably because there's
been people that miraculously recovered
and then they're like you told me to get
off treatment and now you tried to kill
me and I'm good yeah well okay whatever
you know I'm not gonna argue the merits
of whatever outlined cases but in your
dad's case it was very tragic that he
before he passed underwent were super
intense treatments that they did yeah
like in his um just his last week he
went through this whole crazy like
radiation on his brain yeah and it was
such a huge operation and it was already
so weak and just to get him to go
through it with so much effort mm-hmm
and then right after the radiation ended
he was way worse and then like three
days later pretty much it ended so I
don't know how much you can really the
tough one
yeah this there's different stages of
cancer though right so yeah I'm sure
there's so many different lines
different stages and depends on the
person to their body I can only hope
that in the near future people will look
back on chemotherapy as like
bloodletting I hope so so much it's so
barbaric yeah leeches it really is
you're killing your body in the hope
that you killed the cancer first yes the
kind of things study effects that he was
suffering afterwards from chemo it's
like things you can't even imagine like
he couldn't drink water for months you
couldn't drink water after chemo mm-hmm
how do you how can you live without
drinking water yeah used to drink only
fruit juice because for some reason
water just wouldn't go down there
something about water and apparently
that's something that happens to a lot
of people after chemo just all kinds of
crazy reactions like that they can't
even imagine yeah it's it's wild man you
got to appreciate the normal times
because when you're in that extreme of a
situation it's it's impossible to
explain how awful it is mm-hmm you can
possibly understand it no and then in
that moment you're like God I just now
realized how [ __ ] awesome it was
before this yeah
cancer is a [ __ ] anyway just cuz I know
we used to make fun a lot of death the
jaw hole is Steve Jobs point of like he
denied treatment to just ate fruits or
whatever but after seeing my dad's
experience I kind of get it I don't know
what stage his cancer was I don't item
not endorsing people refusing treatment
I don't endorse anything when you got
kind of stars and it's all [ __ ] yeah
you can't judge any decision a mad dude
you set me straight I'm not gonna say
[ __ ] you're right you know what you're
right
you're right I should make fun of Steve
Jobs for eating fruit the guy died of
cancer he tried his best shit's hit me
with the cricket sila [ __ ]
so in short you are not gonna eat your
placenta no okay and they're one of the
wife's make their I think the vitamins I
wonder if why a salad fruit I wonder if
there's wives that make their husband
eat some placenta to I think I I think
people do cuz I try some this kitchen I
saw this like picture post of people
saying like here's me cookin the
placenta and it looks like they're
cooking it for both of them bro if my
wife served me a placenta I would be
like it's I beg damn I wish I knew this
before we had a kid you should have told
me you got it tell me when we get
married if you're gonna be eating
placenta or not next time if you laid it
guys listening if you propose to your
girl say ask them the night before you
propose be like baby what's your policy
on eating placenta
mmm just
make sure it checks out because you do
not want to marry a woman who's into
eating placenta that's the that is the
gateway drug to not vaccinating your
kids anyway we're talking about Dan was
telling me yeah there's this like I'm
not gonna say the company because
they're on sponsor but you can now in
California this blows my mind
when I was a kid to get weed it was so
shady
do you had to talk with like actual
criminals to get a gram of weed yo now
you know you could get an app on your
phone and ten minutes later they're
gonna bring you a high tech vape pen
with ten CBD to one THC you can get all
the formulas and perfectly like little
tech Bay pens and [ __ ] and I'm I had I
don't smoke weed at all I haven't in a
long long time since I was in like high
school so this all kind of just passed
me by until right now and I was talking
to Dan he's like yeah I just used this
app on my phone or they delivered to me
in ten minutes and I was just like what
how is that possible
and so that I want to try this I haven't
spoke to you know long time I try it so
and then I'm telling that happened I was
like wait I can just go in a store and
talk to someone and buy this so crazy
and I go oh no weird yeah
it even feels weird to be talking about
it but it's a local drug leave which I
was like jake drink alcohol no smoking
cigarettes so I got my phone I say we'd
store Google Maps there's three of them
within like five minutes dry that's so
crazy so I think I'm gonna stop at a
weed store I'm gonna walk in be like
guys is the weed store like a narc
growing up having to go through you know
meeting some shady dude in an alleyway
or whatever to be able to walk into like
this pristine store and there's :
shelves and shelves I love people that
are passionate about weed man they're so
enthusiastic it can be a bit much but yo
they're like yo so what mood are you in
you like you want to get you want to
chill you want to work you
play you want to sleep you want to focus
it's like dude it all is the same only
two options one you don't feel anything
one to feeling yeah that's all I've ever
dude
and then whenever I say that even though
if smoke weed look on your times they're
like no you didn't try the right [ __ ]
yeah
yo are you in the mood to play are you
an energetic are you running are you
flying you want to be funny you want to
be sad you want to be pensive you want
to be thoughtful what do you feel like
that asked you that they're there all
the people that work in those kind of
places are totally like that and every
time I'm just like there's no way right
and they say that it's real but I'm so
skeptical that that any that [ __ ] makes
a difference I think it's a placebo
effect personally effect really wants to
say that we should pickle that placenta
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you whoever's
recommended a pickle my turds but thank
you for your subscription at least say
subscribe and every view matters so I'm
gonna go over there yo Cat Stevens
rest in peace he's fallen on hard times
but he has one of my favorite jokes
about weed of all time he goes he goes
you walk in a drug I've cut I'm such a
white guy ruining comedy I'm gonna do my
best here guys everyone's on the edge of
the seat here we got you all ready you
want you when you walk in his story to
go they always make it sound like scree
a crazy as possible they go this was
called death like well you sure that was
Katt Williams Katt Williams Stevens
that's the guy who I [ __ ] that up from
the get-go
Williams sodium the funny little black
gentleman with the straight hair a
little he's short it's part of his bit
yeah I mean he would talk about all he
caught himself a black leprechaun up he
goes you just you walk in and smoke it
and die he's like no not death death you
smoke this you can't hear [ __ ] man I got
[ __ ] to do today but that's how I feel
like weed is different bucks up my whole
day folks in my whole week cuz like that
day I'm [ __ ] up and then the next day
I'm like a little washed out though and
I'm like in my head like oh I'll never
be the same
how many times is that thought occurred
you know I'll never be the same again I
can't believe I smoke the weed again
Here I am about to go but you know why
I'm interested because of this chill one
dad told me about
it's called chill it's got ten parts CBD
to one party THC the CBD stuff it's
definitely a different experience it
doesn't get you high as [ __ ]
like normal weed or oily michael
vibrator did i smoked ready yo are you
in a mood to game you want to experience
you want heightened pleasure what do you
feel like you hungry
you're not hungry you happy
yo what we got here hey is your boy mr.
weird you know what time it is
hey I got the weed you gonna smoke huh
just won't gonna make ya happy
just one gonna make you sad
just one gonna make you sleep this one
gonna make you mad
oh very musical need weed man I got the
weed for with that but you want ha you
know what time it is we smoke the weed
when we happy and then we smoke the weed
when we're not young mom we smoked a
win-win way out to space we smoke away
wake up men and we smoked a whit when we
put the kid to bed
we hotbox the kid's room but smoke da
weed the kid they say it the weed is
good for the kid my wife was pregnant
and she smoke the weed come out and he
say yeah I want to smoke the weed I
spoke to a weed I blowed a weed in my
child's face he crying coughing and I
spoke to weed and then I smoke the weed
a
Wow thank you that was brought to free I
trust pretty good I had that cued up
no it's cool you you basically Zack that
was great what you did is you set me up
for a slam dunk
you ollie you me off the back door
tonight I drove in it's right I was a
great thing was that who did that was
that Danner Zack that was the Zack okay
good props to Zack on that thank you
very much
today is episode 104 the musical hunting
for smoke the weed man is your dick soft
then you bet the smoke though we like
you get to survive like a creepy clone
what I like it it's funny
oh you like it yeah cuz creepy clown
doesn't sound good when your dicks off
your bed to smoke dull weed if you dip
too hard you bear to smoke the weed if
you're hungry then you bet to smoke
though we if you're dying you better
smoke weed
a man is Tuesday brother you smoke in
the weed help me with that music cuz it
just sounds racist without the music
yeah help me brother with the music
alright what is today Friday afternoon
brought up
you know what time it is yes let's smoke
the weed brother hey Friday afternoon we
got the smoke though we may be bad
outside afternoon we gonna smoke no weed
we pulling up weeds we're gonna smoke
the weed I'm doing gardening the gun the
smoke no weed
my mama comes over gun to smoke no weed
my mama come over says I'm dying my mama
she says I need something Denis's mama
smoke the weed I kicked about my house
it was time to smoke the weed
did you ever poof the weed that's when
you booth the weed you inhale a joint
through the eight knots the membranes of
their colon all absorb the weed it's
more potent mine and you get more bang
for your money it's Friday afternoon
yeah Sparta I'm headed down to my local
weed shop brother I walk into the weed
shop and the brats are on the other I'll
say you gonna smoke the weed I say yes
brother we smoke the weed he says are
you sleepy or hungry you're hugging you
wonder if I did what a better gym buddy
I said yes brother smoke da weed you
want a treat
smoke the weed you want to sleep smoke
the weed
do you want to you want to smoke the
weed with me brother
hit him hit him there you go you hating
on a brother because Eli you 18 did
score over here
this girl hatin on a Jamaican brother
useful I smoked the weed and she hatin
on me
I need more hating sounds you know like
can't express we can't smoke the weed
cuz you're pregnant right yeah I don't
think so I can't do anything do you
won't really drink coffee yeah that's
true so I'm excited to go to the
dispensary it makes it and then regret
it deeply I'm gonna be home being like
smoke don't we eat smoke the weed and on
my head it'd be like okay I'm never
gonna be the same again I can't believe
I'm here again I'm smoking weed again
well let's see what happens but you got
the CBD stuff it really is a it's kind
of a different beat this podcast is
longer than Shane Dawson videos podcast
not a video it's a long-form content
it's a podcast everybody who clicks this
knows that it's just some dumb [ __ ]
hello remember how we met speed weed oh
yeah oh my god when we did kill Tony I
met this guy named speed weed and he
owns a guess it was at his name no no I
don't I'm not I don't want to endorse
these products yeah I don't know
anything about this website I don't
recommend it I'm not sponsored by that
it was just funny though he was trying
to get in he wanted me to promote it and
I was like I don't know cuz I either I
do I do have a line of things that I
don't like to promote
on the show like jewel has approached us
hmm
I was like I don't want to promote that
yeah you know you can do it on your own
we can there's enough things to promote
there's plenty of other stuff you know
what are some pits someone's we've
rejected
should we not say I feel like it's
interesting we rejected a alpha brain
alpha brain was very aggressive yeah but
I can't I was like just touch it for two
months then we straight guinea pig
because I'll tell you I wanted to once
on so much because they have so much
money and they wanted it's so bad so I
was like I was like is there any way
that we can do it sounds like Dan can
you take the [ __ ] mm-hmm for like a
month and tell me if you feel anything
I took it religiously for two months and
you know my experience may vary but I
will say I didn't feel [ __ ] but I count
on one hand make fun of people that eat
their placenta and then on the other
hand so [ __ ] alpha brain you know
just not it ain't right
thank you for being the guinea pig
though Dan you be doing hairy shape that
any time what have you got what else do
we reject sports betting he rejected
game loans loans that was one yeah loans
I was like I just don't that's why I
didn't want to be I don't want to be no
that's too I don't wanna be involved in
that and so like not it was a reputable
company apparently they're like internet
loans okay yeah but it's just like but I
yeah loans are such an ugly mess TV yeah
guys you could get
commercials for the army too it's like I
don't believe yeah so weird for me to
see a commercial to the army yeah is
that always so we I agree there's huge
billboards but you weren't drive around
like join the army today
whoa the army needs advertisements to
get people that's crazy yeah what are we
talking about the loans they're like the
copy was like no credit required hmm I
was like yeah well just like guys I
should do like this guy's head on over
to [ __ ] get me in debt calm and no
credit is acquired and also when you're
done head on over to Teddy fresh we've
got a new drop now that you have money
was there something with like sex I have
no problem with flip was it flesh like
then they wanted to send us flush lips I
don't think I wanted to add I think it
was a sex toy website and I just thought
it was too risque mm-hmm I think I think
I would I would take a fleshlight
sponsorship but I just don't know if
YouTube yeah it's a little hard with
YouTube like I have a dude I'm a full
support of flush lights but it won't be
a family-friendly like immediately right
what I am that's what I was concerned
about
I think dude should get flush lights and
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out huh cuz girls you have
all these crazy sex toys and that's fine
it's cute even you seen those girls that
girls have they have like [ __ ] like
they look like nuclear reactors some of
these vibrators you know oh god forbid I
get a fleshlight with a [ __ ] I put my
dick in okay the problem with dudes
it sounds so yeah uncool I know
flashlight I know it's real and the
problem with dude's exercise is a
youjizz and it makes such a mess it's so
gross so if you're not handling that
aspect like in a logical way can get
real nasty get a tool box get it to [ __ ]
a tool box
but your dick in a toolbox now they
started making like flush lights that
have like that does everything for you
this flashlight will suck your dick but
you still jizz in it so it's kind of a
tough workaround
we're gonna need a flashlight they're
like vacuums the jizz up but then you
still have the problem is you still have
to do something with it unless it goes
to like a sewer system I guess people
are saying in the chat that a lot of
people do the flashlight ads Oh for real
on YouTube I don't know I'll do
flashlight I'm fully support them I do I
swear to god I'll leave I'll use one in
the Dorset I don't care I really don't
care I think guys she but did you do
more things cuz girls get all the fun
well I'll put it no you can ask answered
yeah damn let's put a note out to our
agency that we want to work with flush
light I'm serious I'm dead serious like
why is it a flashlight right because
it's like considering that you could
hide it yeah flashlight
but it was no big why are you pulling
from my 19 650 yeah you're not flowing a
ladder
they have butthole flashlights and then
they have like flush lights that are
modeled after certain people's bubbles
[Music]
like pornstar butthole flush lights do
they have to take a mold yes dad it's a
car it's a carbon copy I guess it sounds
like it's fine cuz they're saying that
even Joe Rogan did it and Bobby Lee for
real and we're going today would be the
best partner for flat our show so many
flashlights a [ __ ] one don't buy them
yet though if you're listening don't
know don't go buy them yet hold out
this is known that we run no nut until
we get that fleshlight endorsement
so don't seriously go buy those yet but
the problem with dude I think that it's
hard to beat the old-fashioned way with
it as a guy mm-hmm right because it's
like it's all a lot of hubbub for guys
just like oh all right let's go oh the
girls you need like a nuclear reactor
and like you need like a nuclear-powered
submarine you need like advanced AI to
be like crunch the numbers on how to
give you an orgasm not you specifically
I'm just saying women all right the
dildo has AI hi my name is Alfred I'll
be crunching the numbers today on your
orgasm tell me what kind of mood are you
it I'll be taking your pulse to
calculate your stress levels and I'll be
putting a probe up your vagina to take a
temperature test and to see what your
wall in diameter is today just sit back
relax and I'll do all the work
hi how're you feeling you're doing good
yeah I'm fine
okay I'll keep going increasing
temperature to 82 degrees hike hi this
is your dildo speaking I could sense
that I could sister your mood has dipped
a little bit it's something on your mind
[Music]
yes I'll put on my mind my boyfriend he
just did call me a couple of weeks oh oh
that's you deserve better than that you
deserve that's a shame your beautiful
princess warrior you deserve better than
that alright was they mm yes ela will ya
Ja Rule's the best job rule I saw this
last night when I was in bed and I was
like I gotta talk about this ja Rule
hasn't ruled out fire festival 2.0
[ __ ] day
hey I wonder have you seen either of
those documentaries out yeah right
really
this hoods down he's like [ __ ] you
probably should watch maybe one day
maybe one day I do can you laugh about
it now now it's all said and done I mean
it's not a it's not funny to me
yeah it's heartbreaking to me right okay
that's good it was it was something that
I really really wanted to be special
amazing yeah and it just didn't you know
but you know in the midst of chaos this
opportunity yeah no you get no more
while you try to do fire fest again just
because the publicity like it's almost
the most famous festival more famous and
say Coachella because everyone is about
it it is the most iconic school that
Nikon has totally so you believe that I
know some people never quit men are
taking responsibility there's a lot of
smart people on this call it wasn't
fraud it was just false advertising love
it
how you doing today
[Music]
temperatures set to 85 degrees sounds
like a [ __ ] chainsaw would you like
me to cook dinner for you after this
what is this I just have a note it says
he sounds like Kermit the Frog and the
oh yeah Lance Stewart I never watched
this he did a breakup video with his
girlfriend I guess he was trying he saw
the views that Liza and yeah even got
that video was like 50 million so
they're like dude we should make a break
a video except they missed the memo that
nobody cares about them that feels bad
to say but sorry I mean not as much
people I don't know why it's girl why is
his girl sitting there like a candy
wrapper she looks like a smidge of
mustard she looks like a Twinkie I can
write a rest fresh wrapper I know what
you mean it's wrapped in this gold yeah
look in there like a she's looking
sitting there looking like a piece of
nutmeg from that candy where do you find
this dude she looks like why in this
collar it was like a banana slug out of
all the colors possible I'd like to put
her on a hot dog and eat her you know
she's up there looking like a Tony Award
she looks like a soprano wife she does
Dodi she's got the whole thing what does
she think she is prince who dresses like
that I can't get over her outfit I don't
know where do you even buy that where
does it exist Guido Guido central I
don't know Guido means I think it's
Italian trash
org she's looking like she's looking
very yellow but any at any rate this
videos I mean it's sad I guess cuz they
broke up or whatever but I mean whatever
what can I say I can't feel that bad
they put on the camera they recorded it
they wanted the views it wasn't that
necessary also Lance sounds like Kermit
the Frog listen he doesn't sound like
that I just had a problem with it cuz it
just looks like they're like shitty
acting yeah well they faked everything
so why wouldn't they fake this mm-hmm
it's not easy Miss Piggy it's not easy
Miss Piggy she looks like Miss Piggy
I found this likes unwatchable yeah is
the worst episode of month babies I've
ever seen when did the Muppets turn it
to this weird drama
I thought Kermit and Peggy were supposed
to be funny I loved the few videos after
you had to make a video saying like the
break-up is not fake yes everyone
because I don't know what is this why
are you guys acting they just say they
they monetize everything you know the
top comment was the ghost made them do
it
look at her man mmm she looks like she
belongs on like the solar panel of a
satellite you know they've got like gold
foil he's out there looking like a solar
sale I it's I can't get over in this
outfit and so it's not easy so we watch
like a few more yeah what's interesting
they've lined the shot up really like so
they they put some effort into lining
the shop because it's very symmetrical
it's on a tripod they should chairs
aside there's lots of cuts too and at
one point the camera angle changes which
means that they got up turned off the
camera moved the camera for something I
think what happened is that they
probably already and it's a complete
guess I don't follow his channel but I
think they probably broke up already a
while ago and they already like hate
each other but then there were like wait
but we didn't squeeze the views of a
breakup video yeah we're good at this
look at this david dobrik 50 million
that was the best gift liza gave David
and their their video was real Liza
well yeah there yes this is just a
complete opposite of what also he's a
guy who's known for faking [ __ ] to both
of them so but anyway she's out there
looking like like a Hershey's kiss
wrapper what the nut in the middle it's
more so a buildup of things over time
going back it's not an easy like six
months we've been bickering over tiny
things that you know he's like an
Italian she's like uh she's like an
Italian mom it's like she's in an
audition where she needs to cry hmm
she's auditioning for Italian mom I
don't understand that Italian thing who
though
I what do I know but golly it's not like
flattering either she's really fit like
she's really health conscious she like
puts a lot of work into her body not
flattering she looks like a astronaut
looks like she could pee in that and be
like looks like a Michael Jackson extra
dancer just the MTV Music Awards expert
or is this YouTube video is that a one
piece or two piece you know she wore
that stealing the show she stole all
these I cannot talk about anything but
her outfit right yeah you know that was
a conscious ever she's like I'm gonna
put on the most insane thing I couldn't
match she probably would shock me for
this occasion I was like yo hit me with
that mustard me with that Italian
mustard sheet I cherish that sound bite
those act let's keep behind that yeah a
lot of girls yes so overt age feel so
much like they're acting I just can't
we got the blackface thing we can save
this though I don't know that Bobby well
to discuss that hmm maybe he will though
he is famously half black or white he's
half than half did you know that he's
biracial yes I didn't know that who can
relate I wonder if you what actually I
wonder if we should save that yeah we
cuz there's this huge controversy about
blackface like Gucci did a blackface
thing and then it's carotid apply Malina
yeah and then Balenciaga did a blackface
thing and everyone's like what is going
on and see how I got to oh no sorry no
oh no that's the retro commercial sorry
once y'all go don't sue me
mm-hmm unfollow was the only correct the
record oh and then Katy Perry did a
blackface shoe right yeah I recant my
statement about splints Iago
but um Tom most shocking one is that
Gucci sweater I get them all I guess we
should just talk about it she just
talked about it and so you want to put
up your yeah they released the sweater
during Black History Month which is just
so weird I guess for for listeners it's
a chip Tsar garment it's a I guess it's
a super turtleneck that goes all the way
up under the eyes black and then under
there's a big mouth hole with big red
lips around it so it looks like whiter
is box yeah I mean it's definitely
reminiscent of like old-timey blackface
and what's interesting is that it didn't
come in another colorway it's not like
there was also a pink one with white
dude who the [ __ ] was only the black and
written that's what I was wondering I
saw they made a statement they're like
we took it off all of the shelves I was
like all one shelf no but nobody bought
this right who would buy that who
besides the whole blackface thing who
the [ __ ] would buy that I think that is
the biggest problem with it is just that
it's first of all so ugly yeah let's
start there I mean
I mean I I grapple with this because
there's no way they did that on purpose
I would hope not I hope somebody's
beyond real into this I mean there's no
way they'd be like you know would be
yeah I can't laugh face turtle
I can't imagine so then I saw some
people on Twitter saying so they don't
believe that they did it on purpose but
what it shows is what a lack of
diversity they have because they're like
well there was one black person there
they would have told you this was a bad
idea
what it's a big company that I really
know black people there I don't know
them if not I guess that is a problem
yeah definitely is a problem like no one
at the process of releasing this it's a
product and maybe we shouldn't
it's an Italian company but they're
global they're here they have huge PR
teams yeah
it's Gucci come on anyway I don't know
it's pretty wild I was just like whoa
that's crazy and then the fact that
there were other companies releasing
kind of like the same style let me open
the Prada dolls
so then Prada around the same time just
started come out with these dolls that
have the same kind of blackface vibe
like you know the big red lips and the
dark black skin like here there's like
all the sudden everyone's like you know
what's super and you know the super hot
black face is so in right now we were
saying there's this trend forecasting
services that this company is sign up
for and they help them like predict
what's gonna be in fashion next year so
I had this thought maybe someone goofed
all these companies but I think they're
like we got the fat they're only gonna
tell Gucci and Prada about this so this
is an objet so don't tell anyone okay
so if you guys want to know what
the hottest trend in q1 2019
blackface what big red lips and black
skin have you seen those uh old racist
cartoons from the 1950s like yeah what
about that super racist um yeah I don't
know it's weird here's a guy wearing it
said a separate piece I thought it was
one piece oh well hold on
is it one piece does it matter does it
change does it change the message if
it's one piece I haven't seen this I
don't know this one huh but it's
definitely one piece oh there's Carrie
Katy Perry again the real crime here is
just what the f is that look at the eyes
on this one straight up like do you want
to look like you've got a deformed face
on your foot
imagine going in public wearing that hi
I'm Katy Perry famous songwriter and
performer I've got a new line of shoes
out it looks like there's a deformed
face on your foot I really think you
guys will love it it's got big red lips
in a black face reminiscent of 1950s
cartoons on top of it it's a real
showstopper and have you ever wanted to
look at your own feet and be spit and be
totally have a spook attack be like what
the home buck is on my own feet because
it's so hideous and shocking go to Katy
Perry calm slash asks you pick up a pair
of ass shoes today hmm
and when you're done you got to smoke
though we'd need a shoe which is an ass
on it the fart coming out of it it's
like brown that giant ass with [ __ ]
coming out of the [ __ ] I charge $500
for it you're like yo this and be like
yeah you know
yo we got the trend forecast you know
it's in right now poop coming up above
all we just got that yes
to 2020 q1 poop coming out of buttholes
can be so hot Oh
Gucci we just got word that Gucci's
making a sweater embroidery with an
[ __ ] with poop out of it so in right
now
Katy Perry's like [ __ ] I better go make
some [ __ ] shoes
I gotta make a shoe with it looks like
an [ __ ] coming out of it so in prod
is like that's so 2019 we've already
hoop coming out of the ass the poop
coming out of the ass is so 2019 we're
covering a lot of ground here folks did
we talk about everything I got a a smart
barber in India that's the whole thing
the new emojis are coming out to him oh
I do want to talk about the fans out to
Dan why do you read the email
cuz you spoke to the I can't I'm
switching okay sir
so there's a guy this toy this his name
is uh Dan Oh brown dan no Dan Oh
Bano toys dan Oh bana DN Oh BA and a and
Oh Dan oh Bono so this guy can you get a
good shot of that can you see that yeah
yeah so he takes pieces of other toys
and then repurposes them and repaints
them to make new toys and he makes the
packaging and everything custom pull it
back just here cuz you're out of focus
yeah there you go that's good so he made
a vapenation toy and it looks amazing so
first I was like yo can we like can we
make like a limited run of these and he
was like no because I actually salvaged
these pieces from
collectibles can you spoke drone he said
you remember the details of you haven't
oh I have this yeah I think the emails
and let's see he says so that is from an
M MLB player head the starting lineup
toys with the bill to his cap cut off
and transforms into a the do-rag the
hanging part of the rag is a piece of
Princess Leia's skirt thing the glasses
I made are out of a twisty tie that came
off my loaf of bread oh I see that it's
like the thing in the middle is awesome
so resourceful the arm came from a Bruce
Willis from Pulp Fiction figure the rest
of the body came from an old doctor
Zarkov from Flash Gordon figure with the
feet sanded into flip-flops and socks
did come on
obviously everything gets hand-painted
afterwards it's just a weird hobby I've
had that people seem to suddenly get a
kick out of can't reveal the secret on
the vape cloud sorry I love this part so
big shout out to Dano Dano banano his uh
his Instagram is actually Dano DN o
underscore Brown yeah a lot of really
cool [ __ ] on there at Dano underscore
Brown he makes amazing stuff this is I'm
gonna cherish this thank you for me yes
so cool so this is awesome and this will
remain sealed you know of course
can you imagine opening this we're gonna
have a kid god don't Theodore's gonna
open this like no you just the value on
this just went down it's so pristine - I
almost want to like write it up yeah I
almost want to frame it it is kind of
that good so Dano Dano banana at Dan
then I would underscore Brown so cool
guys if you have anything else
incredible to report please submit them
at any time to podcast at h3h3
productions
calm as we wrap this up I want to say
thank you to ja rule I want to say thank
you to the people who have committed
their life to understanding all the
nuances of weed and the guy who I'm
about to go meet to get the advice the
tenant you know make me have an awful
night I'm too high too high I want to
take my beautiful pregnant wife ela who
always has back pain yes she bears that
load for I've been I've been feeling
totally fine but the only thing is I
started to have this back pain yeah it's
pretty good yeah I'm excited I can't
wait to meet that little shrimp little
champ thank you to Dan our wonderful
producer who is switching and jamming
and jiving back there with him is Zack
the sound guy who did a great job today
by the way sent me up he sent me up for
all kinds of slam dunks ian is not here
we wish him well he's undergoing some
kind of experimental procedures that we
can't talk about but hopefully we'll be
able to someday soon I'm not gonna
pressure
[Music]
he didn't want to tell me because he was
afraid I would talk about it on the air
so I promise not to do that until he's
ready but it's so good oh my god like
good to talk about but awful for him
god bless him won't mention what it was
Friday and thank you of course to
everybody for tuning into this Friday
morning h3 podcast experience we had a
great time with you you know I'm just
being me I'm just being real sometimes
what it gar say just be ironic FRA
sometimes I'm real
so does I'm wrong sometimes I'm just
cool mmm
cuz that's just the way I am or wrong I
know that is just the way I am okay
next week we've got Bobby logic the
performer known as the logic hip-hop
sensation Boy Wonder
sweet man gentleman scholar fascinating
fascinating guy looking forward to that
and that'll be Thursday Thursday the
usual Friday if you have questions
please submit them on the sub R ever
gonna put a thread up right after the
show today yep and with that being said
up y'all have a wonderful weekend
and that's really and just say what up
to ja rule on Twitter because we will
need the fire festival 2.0 updates also
wanna know about his new app I want in
on whatever he's doing take my money
Tyrol yeah one of this I want to be an
investor only be on the ground floor
whatever Ja Rule's working
and shout out to all the parents that
are blackout drunk at Chuck E Cheese
right yeah so throw one to stranger at
Chuck E Cheese for me don't don't yeah
totally to all my dogs out there who put
in their diction flashlights all my
girls with AI nuclear fusion doing work
on their vaginas shoutout
hi good evening how are you today it's
like a black mare episode it is we're
almost on the alright that's about it
we'll see you guys next week hopefully
I'll have a new video for you guys next
week I was so sick I was unable to do
anything so much ass but next week
you're gonna say ass a lot what can I do
it's not that vulgar it's like a good
middle town
feels like I don't want to drop it half
bomb or something yes all right bye guys
thanks for watching thanks for watching
[Music]